hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be talking about
ultrabooks because to be totally honest
ultrabooks are pretty awesome i can't
even count on two hands how many world's
thinnest ultrabooks we saw crowned at
ces 2012 this year uh but if you know
what an ultrabook is before watching
this video if you know the definition of
an ultrabook i dare you to leave it in a
comment i mean obviously i can't verify
that i didn't watch this video first but
uh let's go ahead and get started so
there are certain things that make an
ultrabook and that actually make it
different from a netbook or a laptop or
a notebook or other stuff like that in
order to be an ultrabook you need to
meet a certain set of specifications as
defined by intel who pretty much came up
with the category as a sort of a
marketing project to compete with the
macbook air which incidentally isn't
technically an ultrabook but we'll get
into that in a second if it doesn't meet
these specs it just isn't an ultrabook
so besides their intel processors uh
there's a size requirement can't be fat
ultrabooks with a 14 inch screen or
larger it can be no more than 21
millimeters thick an ultrabook that's 13
inches or smaller can be no more than 18
millimeters thick also to be in this
ultrabook category you have to have a
battery life of at least five hours and
you have to resume from hibernation in
seven seconds or less and these
requirements can actually change as time
goes on to keep them ahead of the curve
and to keep them just as sexy as the
newest macbook air there are no storage
requirements right now uh but according
to wikipedia which is a reliable source
teachers uh the next round of ultrabooks
will be running mostly ivy bridge
processors and will have a minimum of 16
gigs of storage is a macbook air an
ultrabook that's a question we get a lot
technically no because apple doesn't use
the little bit of proprietary software
intel requires called rapid start which
is what helps them resume from sleep so
fast but the macbook air resumes from
sleep that fast anyway so i'd say it
fits mostly all the specs to be an
ultrabook close enough apple close
enough and also google's chromebook is
this an ultrabook well no they're just a
little bit a couple of millimeters too
thick actually to be an ultrabook right
now and also while windows isn't a
requirement these are running chrome os
and they don't use intel's rapid boot
and they use intel atom processors so
basically these fall into the netbook
category not the ultrabook category so
there you have it those are ultrabooks
uh pretty simple definition to be honest
i'm really looking forward to the next
generation of ultrabooks to see just how
well they evolve if you have an
ultrabook let me know which one you have
because there aren't a lot of ultrabooks
out right now so i want to see if it
meets the requirements and i'll
definitely check it out and give it a
look now if you didn't see my last video
it's right there where we got busy with
the asus zenbook ux31 which is one of
the best ultrabooks out there pretty
much a benchmark for what ultrabooks
should be in this generation so check
that out if you haven't already seen it
pretty short video i'm going on vacation
next week so if you guys uh are ready to
take a spring break vacation like i am
enjoy the week off i'm gonna be taking
uh my duties and all sorts of things
down to the south half of the united
states for a week so either way i'll
talk to you guys in the next video see
you in about a week and i'll talk to you
later
peace
[Music]
you